it is January 1st 2024 beginning not
only of a new month but a new year so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'll talk about what went
on in December and what we've got coming
up in January and indeed in some respect
for the rest of the year I always like
to begin by highlighting three big
things so big thing number one I've been
talking about this for a while we've got
an online class coming up that's going
to be starting towards the end of
January so if you want to study with me
it is called ancient philosophy and
friendship and we're going to be looking
at people from Plato and Aristotle all
the way through the epicurian and stoics
and even to some people that you might
not consider to be philosophers as such
but C certainly talk a lot about
philosophy like Lucian the great
saturnist as well so we've got that
coming up uh big thing number two I have
been invited to um start working with
Cameo which is a platform where you can
request videos from people that then you
send to other people I actually got one
of these that my wife had sent to me
from one of the guys from Uriah Heap
along long time ago so maybe you'd be
interested in that and I will put uh
links to that uh below and then finally
uh big thing number three it's been a
long time since I've done monthly
newsletters and I realize it's about
time to begin doing those again so I am
starting up or restarting the newsletter
that will tell you about what's going on
and you know maybe give you some deep
cuts and we'll see what else we're going
to do with it but we've got that coming
up as well so those are the three big
things December is a long but it was a
very very busy month for me so I'll tell
you about the events and then I'll tell
you about all the other stuff that went
on that you might be interested in I was
invited early on in the month to be the
guest in the American philosophical
practitioners Association and agura and
that was a really delightful
conversation with Lou marinov link to
below you can find links basically to
everything that I'm talking about in the
video description uh we also had uh the
next session number 23 of our classic
metal class where Scott truli and I
looked at Guitar Solos and you know what
they're all about and who better to talk
about this then a not only session and
gigging musician who's also got some
albums to his name but a guitar
Professor so we had a great time with
that um I also did a video on the
ornament Trail here in Milwaukee
Wisconsin something that perhaps some of
you who don't live here would be
interested in uh we did uh some wisdom
for Life show uh episodes and one
particularly on the
AI Forum uh I also held my understanding
anger uh session for the month and this
time we are looking at eel's or esta
Trilogy and anger and its role in those
along with revenge and other you know
motives feelings we had our uh ask me
anything session as usual and something
that a lot of people were looking
forward to which is going to be
continued into this next month worlds of
speculative fiction people have been
asking for Steven Erikson's model on
book of the Fallen for a long time
that's a 10 book series we did the first
two books in the series and it was you
know pretty well received by by people
who are serious fans and there are some
serious fans of that uh wonderful uh
fantasy series I also did uh a video on
uh fake quotes this time on Sena so
we've got all three of the really
important stoic figures covered now at
this point we're ready to move out into
other thinkers who have uh often been
misquoted or misattributed so that was a
lot of the video and event work uh it
was also the end of the semester and I
was teaching four academic classes so
that kept me pretty busy four
face-to-face classes on two different
campuses Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design design and uh Marquette
University uh two applied ethics classes
to introduction classes Humanities and
philosophy so that kept me quite busy uh
fairly late in the semester I've been
dealing with a lot of client work as
well and got some writing done that you
can find in my medium publication and of
course it is the holiday season in
December so not only did we have a lot
of uh concerts and events to go to which
were a lot of fun uh we also did things
at almost home you might have noticed
the cats had their own stockings there
was a lot of cats coming in and going
out being adopted uh I did some shifts
with them and then we had my kids here
for uh Christmas time you know all of us
together having a a pretty fun time we
got to see my dad as well down in kosha
we met up there at my nephew's Brew
Pub and uh that all sort of finished up
and then Andy and I had a nice quiet New
Year's Eve together here um what else uh
I've been working on my online classes
that I'll tell you a little bit more
about in just a bit uh the study with
Sadler Academy and I did a good bit of
podcast work releasing a lot of podcast
episodes on two of Ursa K Len's Earth
sea novels specifically the tombs of aan
which is the second Earth sea novel and
then the third one the farthest Shore
which brings the Earth sea original
trilogy to a close we're not quite Rel
finished releasing those uh podcast
episodes but that should finish up this
coming month what do we have coming up
in the month of Jan January so we're
kicking off this weekend coming up on
Saturday the 6th at noon we will have
our usual monthly ask me anything
session you can pop in and ask me
questions not just about philosophy but
personal life my views on things heavy
metal literature all sorts of uh
interesting topics that people tend to
bring up later that day for patreon
supporters we will be having our
philosophy chat and um that is a bit
more intimate setting using Zoom we do
video conferencing that is a perk for
patreon supporters who would like to get
in on that on the 13th uh at uh noon
we'll be having the next understanding
anger online session and this time we
are looking at some more Greek tragedy
specifically two plays that are part
particularly important for highlighting
anger one of them is by Sophocles it's
called the Ajax uh one of the great
Heroes of Troy who just happens to hate
ads' guts and then we have uh one of the
most important plays Ides Meda a
character who is taken as sort of the
epitome of anger Gone Wild in the
ancient world then on the 20th on uh uh
at noon again we'll have the next
classic metal class and this time we're
going to have a special guest kenned
Blackwell who was there in Great Britain
during the uh new wave of British heavy
metal in the early 80s actually going
back to the late 70s and Scott and I are
going to interview him to talk about
well what was it like I mean we got to
see it from the outside and as it
impacted the United States but uh Ken
was there he's been joining us in a lot
of the sessions and this will be the
first time that he's on camera as a
guest so that will be a real treat uh
the next day the 21st a Sunday at noon I
will be getting to that self-directed
study Emmanuel Kant video so my advice
about how to study K somebody I've been
teaching for boy about close to 25 years
at this point um then uh we will be
having a string of things on the 25th at
10 we will have the very first session
of that philosophy of friendship class
which will be an online session starting
at 10 p.m. or starting at 10: a.m.
rather uh uh central time and we will be
meeting for about an hour and a half
looking at ploh and specifically the
listes but some stuff from the Republic
as well that is a class that people can
register for and sign up for it does
have a tuition payment so you'll want to
check that out link will be below uh for
you to to find it on the 26th at 6: p.m
we will have philosophy eats a local
event here at the Women's Club of
Wisconsin and then on the
27th big thing again for uh speculative
fiction and specifically fantasy fans
will be doing uh books three and four of
stepen Erikson's mizon book of the
Fallen series and uh I'm already near
the end of book three and wow is this
some amazing stuff so I'll be talking
about some pretty cool World building
and philosophical themes during that I
hope that you can join us for that so I
mentioned online classes I will be
bringing out some asynchronous that
means you work at your own pace open and
enrollment not for credit online classes
in the study for Sadler Academy I'm
working on one on Plato right now that I
hope to have out within you know a week
or so but we're also going to start
registration for two classes that will
be beginning one in late January one in
early February so philosophy of
friendship looking at ancient
philosophers on friendship who do you
think is going to be in that well
obviously Aristotle right but some Plato
some cisero we'll look at what the
epicurian had to say We'll look at a a
good bit of stoic stuff including Sena
and epicus but there'll be all some
other interesting discussions in there
as well Cicero's on friendship we'll
look at dioc christom a you know sort of
neoc cynic philosopher we'll look at
Luan and at Plutarch as well so that is
going to be a great class lot of
interesting things these people have to
say and then in February so you'll see
stuff for this coming out in January in
February we're going to be doing a six-
week class on the cardinal virtues in
stoicism so if you've ever been a little
bit confused about the nature of the
virtues remember you know a lot of
people say stoicism is this philosophy
that says that virtue is the only good
okay well what are the virtues what are
the places we're going to go deep into
stoic texts to figure that out and we're
going to have to do a lot of like
putting things together and compare and
contrast in order to make that happen a
lot of video work that I've got coming
up so core concept videos we're
continuing on with the core concept
videos that we've been doing for several
months now on a manual cons proma to any
future metaphysics I am teaching an
existentialism class starting this Jan
January for Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design so I will also be doing some
videos on kard and on Kafka and I've got
a video commissioned that I've been
waiting to get to on Del's Delo and
guitaris uh anti-us and the notion of
the body without organs which I'll be
looking at in part one of that work
looking forward to that I've got a lot
of personal videos that I think I'll be
doing including a reprise of one that
was about the perfectionist trap I got
interviewed about perfectionism recently
and I thought that was kind of a cool
topic to go back into we'll be doing
some book reviews some ideas that
matters uh interviews as well and I'll
be telling some stories on the Sadler
stories things and I think you're also
going to see a lot of footage from
almost home whether it's shorts of the
kittens playing or hanging out I'm
thinking about doing a video about that
and perhaps even uh some interviews with
people who've been involved with the
founding of this great institution um
you can also expect to see wisdom for
Life uh recordings the you know
recordings of all the other events that
we're doing including the AMA classic
metal class and then I will be doing I'm
hoping another fake quotes video and
when I ask people who they really really
really thought was
important interestingly the
overwhelming sentiment was was Fredick
nich so I'm going to be digging around
and seeing where people are
misrepresenting n and we'll you know
we'll we'll tally them up and say where
the quotes actually came from I do also
have the podcast so I'm continuing on
with the UR Le Len until we get to the
end of the Earth SE Trilogy and we'll
put off the other three Earth sea books
until later and then I've already
released these to my patreon reporters
uh Sila machold and her fellow authors
uh corporate governance and feminist
ethics a text that I teach when I have
my business ethics classes I did some
good podcast episodes on those and then
we're going to do one that I did some
core concept videos on Last uh semester
Alistair McIntyre how to seem virtuous
without actually being so a great little
article that that he wrote um and then
after that we'll we'll we'll have to see
what we want to do for podcast stuff uh
there's a lot of things that I can turn
into good podcast episodes maybe I'll do
some Sadler shorts we'll we'll see what
what's going to be in the cards so uh a
lot of cool stuff coming up you know uh
hope you can join me for some of these
online events and I hope that it's a
great and happy New Year for all of you
um we we've got a whole new year ahead
and lots of opportunities for you know
making things better changing the script
uh growing personally and you know
adjusting to the fact that we're all one
year older so that's enough from me I
hope I'll see you somewhere in the
internet or perhaps even here in the
Milwaukee area and if you see me at some
sort of event you know do come over and
introduce yourself say hello and and
I'll be happy to see you
there